the stunt that got cut where you're
under water and a chair tied to a chair
that was one of them like the most
difficult thing I've ever
traumatic it was
think about that and I go
like I can't breathe and it wasn't even
in the film it was a giant tank and it
was used for the second film that they
were going to try to take our movements
underwater and make it look like we're
weren't we weren't underwater and they
sunk the entire apartment we had to be
restrained not restrained but weighed
down
so that I could sit in a chair because
as you float your eyes had to be open
that was yeah so that was the other
thing I think that made it worse well
they didn't anticipate there's particles
and things and it started to float into
the water and both Ryan and I got really
severe eye infections are you serious we
couldn't open our eyes for like two days
that they have to like cancel production
for two days yes